[Music]
so before we get out of here I really
like obviously making childish dirty
jokes but to make myself feel better
about making them I also like to couple
them with something meaningful in a
segment we call profound
[Applause]
[Music]
profane and it's my honor to welcome to
the show live in studio from the uh
surfing instructing video Pastor Rob
Bell everybody Rob
Bell
hello Rob hello
Pete acclaimed author Rob
Bell you ready to do this yes let's do
this could we make it a little more
profound in
[Music]
here everybody has Faith everybody
believes in something we're all on a
path the compelling question is which
path has the capacity to transform you
into a more loving peaceful courageous
person there are women who give birth
and they don't know they were
pregnant
they they just thought they had
indigestion but then a baby comes
out it's one thing finding out you were
a mistake but imagine finding out you
were supposed to be
[Applause]
[Music]
diarrhea